Hello BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we are your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
Welcome!
Thank you for joining us today for our 170th episode!
170!
Yeah!
Ruffians!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
We just got back from our first concert!
Yeah, are you surprised?
We're so happy to be able to spend
A new month together with your Ruffians!
And you know, August was such an amazing time!
Lots of stuff happened!
Lots of stuff happened the last little bit too!
Wow!
For those that are joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Right now, FUWAMOCO Morning will be brought to you temporarily on Mondays.
Once a week.
Yeah!
So, you know, we can get a bit more balance in our lives.
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Yeah!
Please put your thoughts into the hashtag!
Hashtag!
FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Hashtag.
Thank you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU
That was a sighting.
Like a... You know, all of hololive English in New York?
Not that kind of sighting.
I was gonna keep it positive, but... You know, you know.
That was a... A Pero-Pero sighting.
Start with the nasty news!
What was it?
Do it.
Where was he slated now, Moco-chan?
Let's take a look!
De-den!
Ruffians!
The boss?
This is a really scary boss!
Are you sure that's a bus?
That's a nasty photo.
A nasty bus.
But, you know, I guess, you know, I've heard that.
New York City.
Public transportation, sometimes you see a lot of different things, you know.
Could be dicey.
Rats.
A pizza that the bus is over.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Sometimes you see Pero too?
You never know!
You have to be prepared!
The pot's is gliding light!
Mistaken.
Hopefully, you know, I think there's a lot of garbage cans in New York.
Maybe Pero finds his way into a garbage can?
Slam dunk!
He's everywhere.
You never know.
Look behind you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
What?
Airport?
At the airport?
Why is Pero at the airport?
You have to check.
Make sure your bags are safe!
Pero could just fly.
You know he has his wings, but... He's nasty.
And he's lazy.
Takes the plane.
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
But speaking of New York... New York?
What happened in New Yorkcon?
Maybe some Ruffians that aren't... I don't know, things are busy.
It's okay, I'm in the booth.
It's okay, don't feel bad.
There's something big that happened!
Yeah!
hololive English, we had our third concert!
All for one!
In New York City at Radio City Music Hall!
It happened on August 23rd and 24th!
Just recently!
Did you see it?
It happened!
Thank you for cheering for us so much!
We had a bunch of fun and amazing show all together!
And you know what?
One kid also got all for one t-shirt!
Oh my!
You were there!
It was epic!
Thank you, Ruffians!
It was the time that we said it all together!
It was absolutely amazing!
And did you see it?
My howling!
Yeah!
FUWAMOCO!
We performed Mio-senpai's original song!
Yeah!
Howling!
For the ones!
And, uh...
We also performed Lifetime Showdown for the very first time on the big stage!
But that wasn't it!
We saw a lot of different songs as well!
And we had lots and lots of different stories!
Wow.
I like those FUWAMOCO Morning stories!
Maybe we could talk about all the other fun things we did behind the stage, you know, backstage, checking around New York, all those things!
Another time, like,
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
BAU BAU!
I know what you're thinking.
You know, well, FUWAMOCO the princess is every day, right?
Are you thinking that, Ruffian?
Right, you're thinking that, right.
BAU BAU!
Right!
But, uh, maybe this is a little bit different.
A little bit unexpected.
It was supposed to be.
FUWAMOCO with princesses this time!
Maybe a little bit selfish.
Maybe a little bit mean.
Maybe.
Maybe not the nicest princess in all the princess palaces.
Kingdoms.
But you can check it out on the official hololive shop!
Preview!
You can preview the English version and Japanese version we recorded in both.
There's also SP voice too, you can listen to the preview for that.
But if you haven't listened to our voice pack before, it's like a full drama series with sound effects and everything.
Lots of stuff going on.
And despite what I have seen, it was not influenced by La+-senpai, no.
That was well before the plus senpai ever caught us.
Our acting is good!
Thank you!
We're doing our best.
It was a little bit tricky this time.
It was really tricky.
I wonder why FUWAMOCO-chan.
I did my best!
Please check it out, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Wow, Ruffians.
Speaking of... New... New... New... New things... New horrors... Yeah, uh... Well, Ruffians, you know, right now it's summertime.
And the summer season is also heavily associated with
We were not cold, we were very very hot.
FUWAMOCO!
We happened to go to Fuji-Q Highland and Amusement Park.
To Japan's most scariest haunted house, Sen'itsumeikyo.
Because of Fubuki-senpai!
Yeah!
We went to the labyrinth of fear as part of Fubuki-senpai's hololive 4 2025.
It happened on her channel!
Yes!
I don't know, Fuwa keeps up as she said.
You know we're trying to test our senses as dogs, as canines, human dogs, to, you know, be able to predict when something scary is gonna be.
It's always better to vote than us.
I don't know how well I did.
Ruffians, something is very important that did not get included.
Do you know?
How long it takes to go through Sanitsumekyo?
It's the scariest haunted house in Japan!
It is in an old hospital.
They built the park around the hospital.
It is 50 minutes long.
5-0!
5-0 Ruffians!
Not 5 minutes!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Mio-senpai.
Hi.
I trusted mama.
We went through Senritsumeikyuu all together.
And it was horrible for FUWAMOCO, you know?
You can imagine the screams.
When we went together with Calli-senpai to Odaiba, we were really stuck to her back.
Apparently things don't get much better because at the end of it Mio-senpai's back was really really sweaty with her sweat and...
My sweat.
Maybe Moco-chan's sweat.
Maybe my sweat.
But how did this happen, Ruffians?
You know, Fubuki-senpai is just like, FUWAMOCO!
Do you wanna go to maybe a haunted house together with me or Mio-senpai?
Oh!
Yeah!
Let's go!
Go somewhere with Fubuki-senpai and Mio-senpai!
Yes!
Go somewhere together!
That's what we heard!
Yes!
Fubuki-senpai knows that we're big, scary cats.
We're demon dogs, but...
So, well, we just said yes.
And we didn't... We didn't know that there was a haunted house this scary in Japan.
And that, well... Yeah.
Yeah.
If Fubuki-senpai said, let's go to a haunted house, you'd go right, Ruffians?
You can't say no, right?
Have you ever been tricked by Fubuki?
I don't think I played this.
Well, definitely check it out, okay?
But at first, Fubuki-senpai made the mistake of having us go first.
Fubuki-senpai said, FUWAMOCO, you have to go in the front.
You have to lead us all.
The first ten steps were very, very long.
Yeah.
Step a minute, right, Moco-chan?
Step a minute!
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
This smells.
It smells like a horse meadow.
It smells really bad.
It's all the scents.
So if you like that thing, you could go check it out yourself.
But otherwise, go watch Ohuhu Miki-chan's channel!
Yeah.
Till you make it out.
We are still alive, yes.
It was really scary.
Yeah.
But, and you know, Fubuki-senpai was pretty scary too.
She was, you know, the game master.
But, she was also really, really nice too because she was like, use the stairs!
FUWAMOCO make sure to breathe!
And if Fubuki-senpai didn't do that, I think I might have passed out.
I felt like passing out.
The stairs were important.
The stairs are safe!
One of the silliest points I think was, whenever there was a door, we'd all try to go through it at the same time.
Just like this!
And the first couple times it was a little bit awkward, we didn't really say anything.
We were just all trying to go through!
And then it happened again!
And then it kept on happening and happening again!
Nobody wanted to go first, no one wanted to be left behind.
Yeah.
I'll go through together.
It's all squishing.
Lots of fluff, lots of fuzz.
I'll squish it through the door.
I can't do it!
Thank you Mio-senpai for being Moco-chan's shield and sweaty towel.
Right, we have more stories we can talk about during hololive.
Oh for one, after party even though it's sort of related, not really related.
BAU BAU!
I'm really happy to be a part of it even though it was really scary.
And speaking of other exciting things!
Advent!
Back at the end of July was our 2nd anniversary!
But just the other day, we had our 2nd anniversary 3D Balls!
We're on the right!
Ruffians, did you watch?
BAU BAU!
What did you think of?
But you know, in 3D Live, we're able to show off some of our driving skills, right Moco-chan?
You're pretty cool.
Drifting, yeah!
The zombie was kinda nice.
I know, the zombie kinda waited for us there.
Except when Shiori almost run it over.
Yeah.
And we got to kinda show our bathing suits a little bit too, Moco-chan.
I like spending time on the beach together.
You know, running and being like... We surprised all fans!
You faked it!
You know, maybe you thought, oh, summer's already over, right?
It's not over, you'd be surprised.
Yup.
And you know, well, we did a bunch of different games and then our faces got a little bit scrambled and maybe things got
What a funny we became hot.
Oi dogs, dobermans.
Dobermans is... That's not what we look like normally, okay?
That was... That was pokey, okay?
It's not normal.
Okay?
We are FUWAMOCO!
Demon guard dogs, not dobermans!
Not chihuahuas!
Nerissa did do a very good job at guiding Biboo and Shiori, huh?
Follow my voice!
It's not working!
It doesn't work, Nerissa!
Wrong eyes?
A lot of wrong!
A lot of wrong Ruffians!
But you still look cute!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru.
Original song series.
The story of Advent!
This time, you know, Persona, it's a little bit more of a slower song.
Slow?
Can you call it slow?
I think so, you know, compared to Genesis or Balian, it's more upbeat.
Alluring!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
It kind of brings out a lot of different qualities in our voices.
And maybe you can hear parts of our voices that you haven't heard yet.
Also, we hope that you'll listen to it lots and maybe we can sing it for you more too in the future.
Oh, please check it out!
It's on streaming services, Spotify.
And you can also check the music video on the hololive English official channel too.
The video's so cool!
Right!
I prefer Genesis for now.
They both play different songs, you know.
Genesis is pretty jazzy.
Prisoner is different.
Thank you Ruffians!
Please continue listening to both Genesis and Prisoner!
BAU BAU!
You know we're having a bunch of fun in New York and then right after the weekend afterwards!
Wow, there was a very special 3-day baseball event going on in Taipei, the Taipei Dome.
It was hololive night with us, FUWAMOCO, Raora, and Gigi!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
Today we are dancing on the beach of Dragon!
There's a bunch of cool stuff going on!
Did you happen to see any of the Ico videos?
FUWAMOCO!
See there's some photos!
There's lots of stuff going on!
And you know...
FUWAMOCO, we did our best together with Gigi and Raora!
We sang some cheering anthems in Chinese!
It was very difficult, but we did our best!
There's cheerleaders that dance to BALADA and ABOVE BELOW too!
That was a light show for all for one!
Of course, lots of merch too!
We were so surprised!
Right!
That was really fun, right?
Yeah, the ball doll dance!
We really liked the choreography for Above Below.
Yeah, Above Below was so cool too!
We are really happy.
Thank you so much to all the fans and everybody who came to cheer and have fun.
Yeah, came to have fun.
Cheer on the Legion Dragons, you know.
Just be there for us and Gigi and Laura.
The girls are so cute.
I'm glad you thought so.
Moco-chan, you didn't think the cheerleaders were cute?
I thought they were cute.
They're cute.
But you're missing the second half of your message there.
Oh.
Did you forget the song we just introduced?
What?
It's okay!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO, you know, even though we don't really know all that much about baseball, we are really, really happy to be there to cheer on the Wing Chun Dragons!
And it really means a lot to us for you to be there cheering, so thank you so much, FUWAMOCO!
Thank you!
More exciting things coming up!
You might have seen on Twitter, but Ayume-senpai!
She's gonna be celebrating her 7th anniversary!
And FUWAMOCO, we're gonna be part of her 3D line!
Not just that too, she's gonna be unveiling a brand new 3D outfit too!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
But you know, despite being a whole year members, you know, I have a senpai that's like... It's like the tricky song.
Sing this together with FUWAMOCO.
So we're gonna do it, guys!
Is it a hot one?
It's a pretty hot song.
My mouth feels like it's on fire.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
That's crazy.
For a second there, I thought maybe we were mistaken.
It makes sense because also there's another big anniversary coming up here too!
Coming up this weekend, there's a special show going on because it's going to be hololive's 8th anniversary!
BAU BAU!
And to celebrate, there's a special fireworks show going on!
Mahou Hanabi!
Shining Sparkling Symphony!
It's gonna be happening at Makuhari-no-hama beach!
It's gonna be happening on the 6th at 2.30am PT.
Or 6.30am JST.
As you can see, it's gonna be hosted by our GenZero here!
I'm so excited!
Fireworks!
So just for hololive you know there's fireworks and hololive night but now fireworks!
Oh there'll be a stream!
There is a stream!
It's available on Zaiko and SPWN but it looks like the website recommends Zaiko for users overseas.
But you know fireworks
Fireworks!
hololive fireworks!
You might be kinda like, huh?
What's happening?
Well, there's gonna be a special show, a fireworks show with drones!
Yes!
And special programming to celebrate hololive's history from the very beginning until now!
Also a DJ set!
I think PandaBoY's on it!
hololive's 8th Anniversary!
BAU BAU!
It's our 8th anniversary, FUWAMOCO!
Happy celebration.
We are really lucky to be part of everything here.
Thank you, FUWAMOCO!
Well, Moco-chan, September's starting officially the 1st!
What happened?
I feel like 2020... 2025.
What were you gonna say?
What year were you gonna say?
I was gonna say 2024.
My pleasure.
How are you feeling Ruffians?
Are you looking forward to a new month?
Maybe a little nervous?
Moco-chan.
Did you want a pup talk?
BAU BAU!
Au revoir!
Ruffians!
It's that time again!
It's time for a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me!
Mococo!
Ruffians!
Can you believe it?
It's already the start of September!
Maybe for you, that means a new adventure to a new school year.
Or, you know, maybe it's just another start to a new month.
But no matter what, it means that exciting surprises await all of us!
Although, maybe you don't want to hear it.
It's officially getting close to the end of the year of 2025.
So, let's do our best to take the rest of the year into our own hands and do our best every day!
Don't be afraid, Ruffians!
Take a chokehold on the next few months and come out the winner!
Got it?
You can do it!
BAU BAU!
Let's do our best, FUWAMOCO!
Let's take a look at some of our regular coordination today, starting with our Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... Korone-senpai!
Morning!
So cute!
I see her fluffy ears.
I haven't seen those before.
I am!
Really?
Why?
You think that she shouldn't be here?
Do you have a problem with this morning?
Morning Senpai is not Doggie of the Day material.
Wow, that's horrible, Ruffians.
I can't believe it.
Well, you know today's Doggie of the Day is Korone-senpai!
A doggy girl!
Yes!
And she's looking very cute.
Just like everyday.
But even more so.
Because she's a Doggie of the Day!
So she looks cuter today!
Moco-chan!
You know, I know Korone-senpai uses this as yubi yubi and other things.
Other things?
But how does Korone-senpai bau bau, huh?
Well, I think there is proof of how she bau baus.
But...
I think it's sort of like BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
Really?
Isn't it more like BAU BAU?
It could be both!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO BAU BAU!
Sometimes.
FUWAMOCO
Korone-senpai was a little bit intimidating at first because you don't really admire her.
We're just newbies, even good dogs.
It's her second anniversary though.
But!
You told her.
She's super duper sweet.
Amazing.
Somehow, she doesn't think that we can bawl bawl away all the things, but she's wrong on that one.
But we love her!
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
It's more her birthday.
No, she's the Doggie of the Day.
You don't have to have your birthday to be Doggie of the Day, okay?
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look.
You know, Ruffians have been all over the boat recently.
Let's take a look at... Today, I went on a walk.
We have... De-den!
Is this a walk?
It's a... Discovery meet on a walk, Moco-chan!
Discovery!
Do you know what this is?
It looks like a good snack.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
But it looks really cool.
I wouldn't want to have one on my hand.
But I think I want to give it a pat.
If you eat it, it will hurt you.
It's definitely crunchy.
Oh, you've tried it before.
I wonder what it would taste like in a cucumber.
Between two slices of cucumber.
I feel like it would be cute to pet one.
I don't want it going on me.
I'll eat it and I'll touch it, but I don't want it touching me.
That's not very fair, did we ask the praying mantis if it wants to be pet Moco-chan?
It's a snack, it doesn't matter.
BAU BAU!
Thank you for sharing a discovery you made on your log!
And next we have our Question of the Day!
Today's Question of the Day is... De-den!
Hello FUWAMOCO!
I'm gonna be visiting Japan for the first time really soon!
Exciting first Japan trip!
Are there any tips or any places you would recommend a first time visitor in either Osaka, Kyoto, or Tokyo?
It is gonna be hot.
It's gonna be hot if it's soon.
It's still very hot.
I know.
Ruffians, was New York City hot?
It was refreshing.
It was not hot in the slightest.
Prepare for it to still be hot!
Get your sunscreen ready!
Places to go!
Let's go to Tokyo!
I think you know what I kind of thought is you should go see Sky Tree!
Sky Tree is a big, big Sky Tree.
But there's also Soramachi.
It's a moor.
There's lots of fun stuff.
Lots of things to see and do.
There's also Asakusa nearby.
Take a look there.
Kaminarimon.
And of course you have to make your way to Akihabara.
No more misto.
It's probably changing, but Akihabara is a very very special place to FUWAMOCO.
Forget, forget about the changes.
It's a very special place.
But you know, maybe you want to check out more subculture, pop culture.
You can make your way to Nakano Broadway.
Check out Manarake.
But for Osaka though, FUWAMOCO, we haven't been to Osaka too much yet.
But there is the...
Very first miso-do store there.
We haven't went!
You could go and discover it and put it back to us!
And as for Kyoto, I think Kyoto, just have fun.
And also realize that it might be very busy.
You might not be able to see all the things you're expecting.
So just have fun.
You know?
Very busy.
But most importantly, just have fun and enjoy Japan!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
We saw so many wonderful
Tweet some photos shared with us, especially during your trips to New York.
Thank you, Ruffians!
We're always looking for new Doggie of the Day's questions.
Pero sightings, your walks, so please let us know what you've been up to with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
And it could be a part of the next episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
We're waiting, okay?
We're waiting!
BAU BAU!
Ah, well, we have another stream coming up soon.
We didn't mention it, but... De-den!
Our FUWAMOCO afterparty!
We have so much we want to talk about!
So many stories!
To share with you!
Maybe not just the concert itself, but you know, New York stories.
Story stuff with, you know, our senpai, our kouhai.
What we've been up to.
Senri to make you.
We have a bunch of things we want to say to you because Ruffians!
You're amazing!
So we hope that you'll be there Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Wow, for Ruffians joining us in the archive today, your FUWAMOCO word is... It's BAU BAU September!
Thank you so much Ruffians for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
It was really really nice to be able to start September together with you.
But before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Great Chailee!
BAU BAU!
Ditto!
Ciaran!
BAU BAU!
P-J-E-N!
Salvi!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru.
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!